this is two more Husein standing in for
reviewer Mike Epstein critics and fans
have thrown around the term tactical
shooter for years to represent any kind
of game that somehow mandates that you
think about how you shoot this
integration is one of the few that
literally blends real-time tactics with
first-person shooting it isn't a unique
mix though the balance of the two styles
feels different than other times we've
seen it over the years the strength of
its parts and the way you constantly
switch between them build up an intense
field commander fantasy as Romish all
the graph cycle flank commander of a
robot Special Forces squad you are the
Scout the artillery the healer and
whatever else your team needs you to be
and yet while it sounds like you're
holding all the cards you still need the
team to do most of the trigger pulling
so your most important role is
shot-caller you tell them where to go
and who to shoot if you don't anticipate
and react to the enemy's maneuvers they
get overwhelmed and everyone dies so as
Roma you are constantly in motion as the
team leader you have a lot of
responsibilities and you need to switch
hats often pointing out new cover
shooting healing beacons and calling on
each of your two to four BOTS on the
ground to use their special abilities
monitoring the skills which include
armor weakening concussion grenades and
fields that slow enemies down is
especially important with a small team
often fighting off much larger numbers
timing and syncing these skills to give
you the upper hand rapidly becomes
incredibly important across the board
though you constantly need to be present
but also focus your attention everywhere
at once managing all these tasks and
keeping a proverbial finger on the pulse
of the battle gets the adrenaline
pumping and can get overwhelming at
times but it's ultimately rewarding as
you come out of each victory knowing
that it was your orders that won the day
that said sometimes it can be more
stressful than it should be though your
allies largely rely on your orders
they're not mindless drones they react
to enemies and to their surroundings but
not always in the ways they should -
often I will direct my team to cover
only to see them stand next to it or
wander out of position to chase enemies
when I specifically told them to hold in
place given the number of enemies thrown
at you in certain situations you really
need your soldiers to follow your orders
precisely especially when those orders
involve keeping themselves alive the
problem feels especially frustrating
because of the game's artfully sparse
checkpointing which reflects natural
sequences but often leads you to repeat
10 to 15 minutes of gameplay if and when
you die at the climax of a scene by
default the strategic elements of the
gameplay take up far more of your time
than the shooting but surprisingly it is
possible to change that if you bump the
difficulty down from the default
maverick settings you become less
reliant on your teammates to do the
shooting
you stay alive longer so you don't need
to mind them and Roma's guns are more
powerful you can't forget about your
team but the dynamic shifts to a more
shoot or forward type of gameplay it
feels like a different game but that's
not a bad thing despite overtures
towards asserting itself as a sci-fi
epic this integrations plot feels rushed
it's a shame because there's a lot of
instances of good extra narrative
storytelling in the game the concept of
integration where most people have
transferred their consciousness into
robots leads to a lot of interesting
world building wrinkles including lots
of small character building moments
without a strong plot though it's
ultimately forgettable
I'm sure in addition to the story this
integration does allow you to show your
mastery of its unique strategy FPS
hybrid gameplay in competitive
multiplayer teams of up to 5 players
each with their own AI controlled crew
go area in familiar rifts on multiplayer
staples like team deathmatch and king of
the hill only one mode of the three
retrieval actually requires you to use
your bot squad in a novel way no matter
what mode you play the more a player
feels a lot more like the shooter
version of disintegration then the
strategy version you
a iBot died with you so there's a strong
incentive to use your squad as a buffer
and target other players other than
retrieval where you have to use a bot to
carry the core the dynamic of being a
commander largely goes out the window
they aren't unhelpful but the strategy
isn't necessary beyond minding their
abilities without that it's a
well-crafted
but basic FPS multiplayer mode the full
team 505 scrums with everyone's BOTS
duking it out looks pretty coarse so I'd
recommend checking out at least one or
two matches of that just to see it
when this integration works it really
works you really get the sense that
you're in the thick of it the heart of
battle of the excitement and stress that
induces are testament to how thoroughly
the gameplay draws you in there are
elements around the periphery of the
experience that could have been better
tuned though but they don't detract from
what makes it work
[Music]
[Music]